こんにちははじめ市立青ね皆さんお買い物する時どうやってお関係していますか
まあ僕は室杉江た開催も買ったことだしこれ財布から小銭とかねお札を出して究極竜
ンって入ってくるんですけども
ちょっとじゃないスマートさが足りないですよねなんか僕みたいにごスーツ着たりし
てる
社会人の方が合ったコンビんだ
見かけたりしてを会議するところ見ると誰も税金を使ってないんです皆凍ってスマホ
持ってスマホ決済でステマでってもうすすげーすぐ傍に見せて
いいなーかっこいいなーってあの北小笠木すぐ思ってまして
まあ一種の後の嫉妬心といいますかその憧れを抱いております肇社長ですあの本気で
生まれてこの方一度もスマホ決済とかそういうなんかをされ気づいたことをやったこと
ないんでこれを機会に行ってみたいということで今日は
スマホ決済やっていうと思いますでですね私今回どうやって様を決済するかと言います
と最近リリースされたキャッシュレスサービス
寝るぺーメル米はですねメルカリを使った決済サービスのことなんですけども
一番のポイントはメルカリで物を売ってその売り上げ機もの歌時の振り上げ気を使って
公民などのめるぺ加盟店
で支払いができるんですなんでアメリカに使ってる方多いと思うんですけどもそれで
もうこうやって入ったうや木金でプロのお店で
ものを書いたりするわけでございますですね id 設定もすごい簡単みたいなんです
よ
あいついうわけで早速めるぺぺーの設定をしていきましょう id 載せてすごく簡単
らしいです
画面で土産
いいとお店で使うそうこれをしたいんですよもうね
リンギオだんだしたくないですよスマホだけでもやりたい
はいべきポイントが練習マネーとして使える全部はず10万カ所でお伝えが可能
澪は誰を見せ多くないですかローソンセブンイレブンミニストップガスト
マクドナルドファミリーマートすき家いろんなおりで有名なメジャー補佐
利用していると思ってもいいのではないでしょうかスマホでできる設定等さは約1分で
できるらしいですね
アプリで電子マネーカードを作りますと始めます
はいっ
んお茶屋もうできた一般お墓なんぞこれ
キターこれでメル米 z マネーがアップル便で利用可能になりました
これで俺もどうやらでも待ってください
まだ私にはポイントがありませんこれでですねえっと私今予約設定できたんですけども
売上金が0円そしてポイン
たわ0ポイント何もありませんというわけでここからですね私はメルカリで売り上げを
出さないといけないということで早速は員の私物でもでいきましょう
重いというと僕がですねスーツ着てるせいもあって着なくなった服をいつも九州で準備
しました
こちらを見る影で出品していこうと思いますたぶん綺麗に写すのがポイントなん
でしょうね
様子うって
います
水瀬を買ってくれ
カテゴリ服灰色稼ご員は2
授乳この服方もだいたい500円ぐらいにしておきましょう
完売利益に治療くさいんで555円で出品します
あっはっは
すっぴん鑑別 masa どんどんていきましょうそう
[音楽]
はいというわけで打ち私の窮するの二期の出品が終了いたしましたべだがですね
まぁだいたい未だに555円って感じで打ったんですけども
ヒョウ柄の服だけちょっと高く浮いた曲ですねこちらだけ1100円くらいに設定させ
ていただきました
これちょっと売れる度を待ちたいと思いますでは
[音楽]
はいというわけであれがしばらくだったんですけども無事
大江そうです
ございま相手に無事全部買っていただくことができました
入って言うけどこれ私は売上を出したわけでございますハイ2期でこれでですねご覧
ください私の売り上げは今
瞭然99円でございますでこのメルカリの売上金4999円で年米のポイントを購入し
ます
分岐うん者から抗議するポイント全部いきます全部
5000ポイントですねじゃあポイントを購入します
ほいったイヤッハーこれで8
メリ米のポイントが4999ポイント
入りましたこれで出来るぞねまた彼ら俺がその加盟店に行ってこれで
う
フォースって凝っちゃったら相手ができるわけですよ
というわけでみなさまこれを使えばいろいろあるんですけど遠回しで要約すると
メルカリだけで生活できるんですたくさん加盟店があるんで多分もうこの
めるぺぺーのポイントだけで僕はんさんいけるんじゃないかと思ってまして
今日から3日間今私が持っている
両1999ポイントは逆5000ポイントだけで
生活を致します3日間で3日間だけ3日間ね授業ですねまぁ皆さんもどんなとこで
買えるかとか何かユーロを遂げたこともあるみたいなのでそれも踏まえてめるぺい生活
ぽっこいっ
ございます田治米社長ですというわけでメルヴェ衣生活
1日目のアースで何だろう碁聖ポイントしかないんでちょっと使い方の感覚は館内でば
てうるさかったではないでしょう
廊下の撮影ですでは早速朝ご飯画素で食っていきましょう
つーわけでまた5000ポイントかでプリントバルーンで割とに攻めキーで言っていい
んじゃないかなと思います
まずはガストで優雅な朝ごはんを食べようと思います3日間だと給食あれから
打ち水約555人しか使えていくんだ意外といいねの朝はしっかり食べた方がいいと
思うので
はい1まいりました木とローンをお願いします
1日平均555円なんですけど大丈夫かな
多分大丈夫だと思います振動がずっと削っていく作戦だと思うんです朝はしっかり食べ
ましょう
こんなお酒考えていこう
1自分にとロードンでございますであります
ねえなった
[音楽]
はいというわけで美味しかったですでガストなんですけどもなんと20%オフの
クーポンが手みたいなんでもうちょい安く行けるかも知れませんめっちゃお得です
ではお会計に行ってきませんこっちラっぽいですね
リカバリありがとうございを指していたします
最近のメイクのな状態でございますメル米で終わります
はいありがとうございます
をそう4風匹てったっへございます紅茶の日階でございましたん
小沢さん方がてくださいませ入ってゆけで1日目のお昼でございまー示またそんなに
お腹が減ってないんですけどもセブンイレブンで買わせていただきました
はいこ空和風ツナマヨネーズですで山がです残り150円なんですけどもあのめるぺ
ぺーアレイぞ
なんとこちらの握り
11円でした ruby 使うとあのクーポンで10%1円で買えました
や莫大の爆裂的な土木の計算と1日555円くらいしか使えなかったんですけどもこれ
10ch で書いた線です相当楽になりました
まあ起きればこれでなんとかしておきましょうはいで上げます
[音楽]
う前たいときで食べ終わりましたごちそうさまでした
いやー結構だ言ってるにやばくねぇを握る10ch 手や口に入ったら俺がで中学生の
頃だったため涙流しながら大歓喜してたと思うんですけど
混ぜお得だと思いますてに使ってみてくださいでは夜まで
ハイテクでよるでございます2チームの夜ですえっとです今日一日で朝からガスト
セブンイレブンでココイチでお持ち帰りで買ってきました
3つ合わせるとガストで777ポイント使って7で11ポイント使ってココイチでと
カレー
卵月に暑かったですけど659ポイント使いました
というわけでスクランブルエッグのポークからやってきたんで食べていこうと思います
いただきますけど太陽している店舗は多すぎてまじですごいた僕が
期頃行くお店ほとんどめるぺでなんとかなります本当に
ちょっと今深夜なんですけども境界はたくさん食べますいただきます
[音楽]
問題にも言うことはないただうまい
はい食べ終わりましたごちそうさまでした
全然いけるぞなんか正直ですね外食とかばっかりなんで3日目ルビー生活ってもさすが
に5000ポイントだときついと思ったんですけども
1日目でなんと1000ポイントも使ってないぐらいなんですよ
これ余裕やでなる美味しいご飯沢山食べるでこれああ
家でというわけでこんな当時で2日目3日目もいこうと思いますではおやすみなさい
これです2日目の朝です影響朝からその別納ショートあるんでシャキッとしてフーガ
つけるんですけどもちゃんと浅川かけようと思いまして
ローソンで買ってきました8ローソンでまずまずは野菜をしっかり取り入れるという
ことで一部前後んだぞ
よかった98年であとちょっとまだダイエット
ちゃんとしようと思っているこちらの糖質を摂るクラとして卵を進めしっとりパンに恋
を張ってきましたこちらの統一多くを作ろうとした時間がないんで結構
髪型も京都と思ってるってちゃんといただきます
これで糖質なぁ点4ですよアクアドアてますね初杭で申し訳ない
この字はやっぱり軍艦がないでしょ
[音楽]
はいぐっと試したを抱いています入ってゆけで2日目の起きれば
マックを食べようと思います
ダブルチーズバーガーと cls ストロベリーです
[音楽]
ありません
えっっ
た
入っててよかったーー
[拍手]
ん
うん
チェーンもねー
[音楽]
やさしい大4俺はみんな詰まっ
とキンキンの世論と済んだはず
ねぇ
ん
はい時の秘蔵吐くから大食いだしましたーー
愛的に2日目がよりでございます今日も撮影とか色々頑張りました
おすすめさまでした俺臼田目の夜はですねー
めっちゃてるんですけどかっぱ寿司で買いました
値段されシート水にさんアプリで見るの結構便利だと同然で僕
こちら活発せて1200キーポイントで買いましたいやマジねーやっぱおにぎり図1が
まず響いている
1,209円のこの寿司の詰め合わせを買っても全然痛くも回校内で頂けます
んまぁ
me
jr ん
やっぱり大手花方とか食べたことないんだよな詰め合わせだと水のネタが多いなまた
これ山
なんならハ2穴子よどんな子が住んでをいただきますうんうん
また旨い
[音楽]
うーんおっとうさまでしたばい
はいジョブ2日が今終わったわけなんですけども現像を見てみましょうか現状ですね
残りのポイントが2175ポイントございます全然余裕じゃんぼインド履歴を見ると
ですね
4999分に入ってガッとで777ポンと払った後に眺める彼からのプレゼントって
いうので500ポイント入ってるんですよねその後セブンイレブンのおにぎりで11
ポイント
高1で659ポイント別居ですねはいてで2日間たて残りのポイントはですね2175
ポイントでございます何かと2メルカ e さんからのプレゼントみたいな感じで
500ポイント入ってました
out はいというわけで所2175ポイントであと1日
軍人年
溶融では愛おはようございます右手良い生活3日日の朝でございますつまり朝じゃない
ヒールですもうお昼になっちゃったんですけども
ネット今回はまたちょっと家の近くのローソンで買わせていただきました
紅に飲んじゃったんですよねえと r 1とスコールのゴール年配もう
呼びかけですけど昼ごはん設定でもなしまきたまごっと味噌
初集買いました山路クーパーが引いててこれだけ買っても残りのポイントです
残りのポイントが
1300生300初17ポイントまあだ
イケますねあと2食分やお昼だから抹茶生不可
また1300ちょいでプレゼンし乗り切ろうと思いますいただきます
いただけません
[音楽]
dea
aname
対ドルで3日目がお昼ご飯でございますってはもうほぼよるなんですけどね
今回はバーミヤンでお家帰るのメニューを変えました
3等ず回鍋肉へ豚肉ときくらげの卵にカラー芸バルサミコ9
ああああああああ
ゲームお持ち帰りでバーミヤンの持ち帰りしたことなかったんですよびっくりしました
ね
じゃあマジでもそのですけどいただきます
うん
[音楽]
ただひたすらにう万円なんかねえめちぇりーがすごい好きなんですよね
まあエビアレルギーなんですけどね
多分なんですけどもうメシュクなといっしょ軍がないんですけっこうこれ誰だったん
ですよ
直径約71ポイント使ってるんですけどもなければ見返すとメルカリからのプレゼント
でまた300ポイント入ってる
退職で残りポイントがね
ぺの結構ギリギリ716ポイント
この造成最後の夜まで出逢っ
はいというわけで米生活に壁の最後夜ご飯でございますだけど最後は普段私がよく使わ
せていただいている好きやで
親と思います716ポイント mother 結構あるんですけど
すき家の凄いところがですねなんとをも使えるの牛丼弁当の並盛がビッグ変な日々
ぐっポッ
やバックないいや僕この年になって結構やバッタもんですけどこれから中学生とか高校
ってのを聞いたら涙流すぐらい安いんですよというせっかくお店人気なんですけど
ちょっとクーポン使いたいんで
お持ち帰りで買って帰りたいと思いますもう使えるので
と中丼弁当の並盛りを浮遊金からただツールでも貼っているのに子でいいよはい
[音楽]
で空港を伝えたいんですバージョン1いいね
ん
やくださいにゃんっ
普通などに使うだけなのですっ
ところが命名の牛丼の150円引きを使っていただきますねを
ています
1,550円の
メール米でお願いしますはい
です猫準備希少価値は即時ですね
[音楽]
うまいでしょですありがとうございますほしいとこちらからお降りください
ありがとうございましたありがとうございました映像なくていた俺がしてすと
あるん
romanian
[音楽]
はいというわけでメルぺー生活3日目の最終日無事
すき家で牛丼店に入りましたーーー
ひどいこれにいいじゃないんですからね僕の分やばくないって200円ってはい10時
で空母でかなり得して変えまして
所々では166ポイントで無事最終日に行くことができました
200円引きかなりでかかったんで頭の部分でですね
たちの分も交えたという字せますしゴールだと思います本当にたちょっと3日問題なく
食べれました
英語
思いますいただきます
ません
いやで今ですね目に米では様々なお得なクーポンが配布されておりますブルガリを使っ
ている方も今買ってない方もぜひ
ある米でこのお得な期間に l 米生活を始めてみてはいかがでしょうか
メディアですねメルカリのアプリを起動して面ペイのアイコンを押すだけで始められ
ますのでぜひ皆さん使ってみてください
れ軽いのアプリのダウンロードはどんなの概要欄からできますぜひ皆さんダウンロード
してみてください
時です呼吸枚売ってを飛ぶのクーポンせわー
3日間女優を持って生活できることが団がありましたじゃん
うーん
まあ
女
うーんのが
持っ
もう
[音楽]
わっ
持っ
あああああ